what does what does a nice guy look like
like the wit the one that you write
about in your book okay and i'll talk
about specifically nice guys but also
say that a lot of things i talk about a
lot of of your women listeners will
probably relate to as well because
there's been nice girls around forever
okay so it's the same it's the same
problem for men and women and it's at
his base it is it then manifests often
in a little bit different ways for men
and women but the base core paradigm is
a nice guy or a nice girl doesn't
believe they're okay just as they are
and you know we mentioned adam lane
smith and he did a really good job
talking about how children internalize
at a very young age
any negative painful experience as being
caused about them all children are very
narcissistic they're the center of their
world and so when something painful
happens we believe i must have caused
that
which then turns into a grandiose belief
system that has two sides to it one is
that i'm so bad i cause people to leave
me hurt me cry be depressed drink yell
scream whatever
and if i am that powerful to cause that
i also must be powerful enough to
prevent that or fix it so there's these
grandiose beliefs that there's something
so bad with me that i caused people to
leave me or hurt me
and i must be powerful enough to prevent
that from ever happening so so nice guys
and nice girls basically then grow up
and by the way this belief system is
recorded at a very deep emotional part
of our brain uh it's recorded in our
amygdala where our emotional operating
system is so this isn't like words we
have it's not an intel
intellectualization it's not even like
visual memory it's just an emotional
belief system down in our operating
system that then affects every other
part of our brain and so we grow up to
be children adolescence adults with a
belief system if i can just be good
enough
and become what i think other people
want me to be then i'll be liked and
loved and get my needs met and if i can
hide anything about me that might get a
negative response from other people then
i'll never get abandoned so
men and women both
that they if they have these nice guys
internalizations or attachment issues as
as adam smith called them um
they might manifest differently for a
guy than they do for a woman but the
core belief system is the same is that
there's something wrong with me i'm not
good enough that's typically called
toxic shame i have to become something
different become what other people want
me to be and hide those whatever that
bad thing about me that i think is and
you for most nice guys what we tend to
hide is our needs our wants and our
sexuality so we we keep that all under
wraps so we don't get a negative
reaction from anybody
okay so would that kind of
would that kind of nice person arrive
from a childhood that was like overly
stressful
is that where it comes from or could it
be a regular childhood and then you end
up like that anyway you know the word
stressful is probably a really good
application because what happens and i
write about this in my book is when i
first started looking at nice guy
syndrome i was looking at me right so i
thought i'm a nice guy uh how did i
become a nice guy well it's probably
because i had this interaction with my f
this type of interaction with my father
this kind of interaction with my mother
i was brought up in a fundamental
christian church that had a lot of you
know hellfire and brimstone messages uh
just grew up in the 60s and 70s with
angry feminism
every man's a rapist and erections a
sign of aggression and so i all these
got internalized into my emotional brain
and i thought okay maybe all other nice
guys are just like me but i quickly came
to realize they weren't um there's a lot
of different factors and and the this
you mentioned stress
however we might experience stress and a
lot of this has to do with temperament
because you can have two children born
into the same family with very different
temperaments and they handle the
stresses very differently and develop
different survival and defense
mechanisms so a lot for for what i found
with nice guys and nice girls for many
it partly just do our next to our
natural temperament i'm a fairly easy
going
you know don't rock the boat want to
make everybody happy kind of guy it's my
basic temperament yeah yeah okay yeah so
that's part of who i am and then when
you add those stresses as you speak of
and those stresses would be anything
that's painful uncomfortable you know
you you went through a lot of painful
things as a child i had surgery at five
days old and i can just imagine
emotionally what that felt like to have
you know back then you know parents
didn't come to the waiting room it
wasn't nurturing and soft and you know i
probably would just take it away from my
parents put on a cold table put a mask
over my face and wake up in pain and you
know how does a child at five days old
internalize that information um it's not
going to be done logically it's done
emotionally
and so
whatever those stresses might be it
might be you know our parents don't get
along well it might be
that
you know that they repress their
feelings it might be that sexuality is
repressed in the family it might be that
mom and dad fight a lot it might be our
you know or maybe our father was never
there it could be any number of things
it could be that we were hungry and
didn't get fed quickly or we you know
wet our diaper and didn't get changed
quickly
those kinds of things are the stresses
that a child internalizes i've got to
find a way to not keep experiencing
these these painful experiences and all
children do this not just nice guys or
nice girls all children develop defense
survival mechanisms to try to do two
things number one cope with the
uncomfortable feelings they're feeling
in the moment so i sucked my thumb until
i was in kindergarten that was a coping
mechanism some children become needless
and wantless some cry some fight some
some please some smile all the time um
that's how we try to manage the
uncomfortable feelings the second thing
that we try to do is try to prevent the
things that cause these uncomfortable
feelings from happening again in the
future
now take all of that bundle of stuff
that we just talked about fast forward
that into adolescence and adulthood we
all have that emotional operating system
we formalized at a very immature
helpless dependent stage of life and we
assume that's the way the world works
and we go out into the world opera
functioning from that emotional
operating system and even if for example
we can't find any big trauma in our life
or our parents are still married and
have a good marriage
anything uncomfortable or painful
is stressful to a young dependent child